Justin thanks a lot Casper so I for this
talk you will not have to know anything
at all about quantum algorithms and this
is joint work with mark button who's
here at the Symons Institute for the
year in Rodman Kothari who's at
Microsoft Research so as the title
suggests this talk is focused on query
complexity and in the query complexity
setting there's some known function f on
n bits and an unknown n bit input X and
the goal is to evaluate F on this n bit
input X while minimizing the number of
bits of X that we look at so the the
only thing we charge for in the query
model is looking at bits of X so we
don't it we don't pay attention to
runtime or anything other than how many
bits of X we look at so in the classical
query model you can imagine that there's
some Oracle and anytime you ask the
Oracle the question I it returns the
ithe bit of X and that cost you one
query and this talk is about quantum
query complexity and the details of the
model are really not going to be
important you you just think of it as
the classical query model except now we
can query bits in superposition that's
really all I want to say about the
details of the query quantum query model
but I do want to say something about why
we should care about quantum query
complexity and they're really three main
motivations for this talk so one is a
motivation from quantum algorithm design
ok so although the query model only
charges for the bits of the input that
you look at and it doesn't charge for
runtime or anything like that very often
quantum query algorithms can be made
time efficient ok so the query setting
provides a very clean abstraction in
which you kind of ignore a lot of the
details about making a quantum algorithm
run quickly and you just focus on the
query complexity and then once you have
a low query algorithm it's very commonly
the case that you can then make it run
fast anyway and in fact many of the most
famous quantum algorithms were either
discovered in or can at least be cleanly
described in the quantum query model
okay so that's one major motivation for
why we're studying quantum query
complexity another motivation is from
classical pack learning so if you show
that a function or class of functions
all have low quantum query complexity
say at most D then they can all be pack
learned in time about end of the D even
in the agnostic model so the details of
that aren't important but this captures
learning in the presence of adversarial
classification noise it's a very
challenging learning setting ok so
quantum query upper bounds don't just
give us a ficient quantum algorithms
they also give us efficient classical
learning algorithms and then finally
there's motivations from circuit lower
bounds so if you show that all circuits
in some circuit Class C all have sub
linear quantum query complexity well
that's a very strong structural
statement about C and in particular in
the black box manner that tells you that
no circuit from C can correctly compute
the inner product function even on
slightly more than half of all inputs ok
so you prove a quantum query up or down
for circuit class and you get out lower
bounds circuit lower bounds against that
class and there are other motivations as
well but these will be the three main
motivations for this talk ok so
hopefully now you all care about quantum
query complexity so the only real fact
about quantum query complexity that I'll
use in this talk and I really won't even
use it that much is the fact that the
quantum query complexity of the or
function and the N function is is root
end ok so quantum algorithm only needs
to look at about root n bits to
determine whether you know at least one
of those bits is a one or at least one
of those bits is a zero so classically
we need to look at at least a constant
fraction of the bits even for randomized
algorithms but quantum way we can do
better that's pretty much the only
actual fact about quantum query
complexity I'll use in this talk ok so
anytime you define a measure of the
complexity of boolean functions one of
the most basic questions you might ask
about that measure is how does it behave
under composition under function
composition
given two boolean functions F and G we
called their block composition just the
function you get by feeding a bunch of
copies of G into F where each copy of G
is to find on a disjoint set of inputs
okay so we're really just composing F
and G that's what block composition
means I mean it turns out quantum query
complexity behaves really nicely under
composition so the quantum query
complexity of the composition of F and G
is just up to a constant factor and the
product of the individual query
complexities yes so this is this is
really nice deterministic query
complexity also satisfies this property
although that that was been known for
much longer
tomorrow I think Chorley is going to
talk about whether randomized query
complexity satisfies the same kind of
notion so that that I believe is still
open for randomized career complexity
all right the point of this slide is
just that this is a basic question about
quantum query complexity and it's
understood and the behavior is about
exactly what you would expect okay so we
totally understand quantum query
complexity of block compose functions so
this work is interested in kind of
moving beyond block compositions so
we're interested in what we call shared
input compositions so now we're
composing F and G but each copy of G is
not defined on a disjoint set of inputs
the copies of G can share inputs so if
you have any such so this is really some
kind of circuit right and if you have
any kind of circuit like this there's a
trivial upper bound on the quantum query
complex in the circuit which is you
ignore the fact that these copies of G
or sharing inputs this is only like
pessimistic so you can get the the upper
bounds that the query complexity of the
composition is and most the product of
the query complexity of F and G that's a
valid upper bound but it might not be
tight so the main question we wanted to
ask is it is it always possible to
leverage the sharing of inputs to do
better than this upper bound and our
main result is that the answer is yes in
a very general setting namely so long as
the inner function is the end function
and also so long as the quantum query
complexity of the outer function isn't
isn't basically maximal
it is significantly smaller than n all
right so as long as these two conditions
are satisfied that is G is the end
function and Q of F is sub linear in n
then we can do better than you can do if
you ignore the fact that this is a
shared input composition nothing just
all you know is that there are only n
bits of input and their shared
arbitrarily between the copy is a G
nothing but then the then there can only
be let's just say for simplicity that
you know every copy of G has the same
number of inputs and they're all
disjoint then there can only be if there
are T copies of G there can only be an
over T G's and that kind of will limit
the quantum query complexity of F yeah
so the here let me just tell you
quantitatively our main result and then
we can revisit the question it's so our
main result is that for this kind of
shared input composition so basically
any any function on n bits where the n
bits are first fed into a bunch of n
gates and then those n gates are fed
into F the quantum query complexity is
that most the the geometric mean of N
and Q of F poly log factors so the the
key comparison point is what is the best
you can show if you ignore the fact that
these inputs are shared you know if you
pretend like these are just disjoint
inputs and the answer is if you ignore
the input sharing the best you can show
is that the quantum core alexia the
composition is at most
the product of Q of F and and root N and
that's this root end is coming because
the quantum query complexity of end is
root n so what we're saving here is a
square root of Q of F factor and that's
significant as long as Q of F is
noticeably less than n if Q of F was n
then this bound turns into something
actually bigger than n and that's just
trivial because of course you can just
look at all the bits
any questions about the main result
so that's our main result I'm going to
actually spend most of the talk talking
about implications of this main result
but I will try to give you an idea of
how we show this actually how the
quantum algorithm works and again the
only the only fact you'll need to know
about quantum query complexity to
understand this outline is basically
that the approximate degree of the or
function is like root N and you show
that through a quantum algorithm called
grover search which is capable of
searching a bit string and looking for
like a 1 a 1 bit in that stream before
we get to the algorithm I mentioned we
show an analog of this result for
approximate degree so if you just
replace quantum query complexity with
approximate degree in both sides of this
theorem statement the the result is
still true approximate degree was the
notion and in Sasha's talk from this
morning I won't say anything else about
it it's related to quantum query
complexity but it's not the same and the
last thing I mentioned is that both both
results with approximate degree or with
quantum query complexity they're both
tight actually there's a there's a
simple example that shows it's tight
that example is actually block composed
although that that details not important
so in general you cannot improve our
composition theorem ok so I'll give you
a broad outline of how this algorithm
works so the idea is that we're going to
try to look at bits of the input with
the goal of killing end gates that have
high fanon okay so the idea is if let's
assume that all of our end gates are
monotone just for simplicity without
loss of generality if we if we look at
an input bit X I and learn that X is 0
then any end gates that that X is
connected to has its value fixed to 0 so
we're going to try to kind of find a lot
of 0 bits of the input that are
connected to many - and end gates
thereby killing all of the end gates of
- and very quickly so our goal is to
basically eliminate all of
and gates that have Fannin more than n
over the quantum query complexity of F F
was this outer function that you're
fitting the end dates into because if we
do that then we can when I say the
trivial upper bounds here I mean the the
upper bound that ignores sharing of
input still gives us something strong
enough right so if every end gate has
fan in less than n over Q of F then just
pretending like ignoring the fact that
the inputs are shared and just applying
the disjoint inputs bound you get that
the quantum query complexity the
composition is at most Q of F times
square root of n over Q of F and that
gives you exactly what we want so we
just have to kill all of the end gates
with fan and more than n over Q of F
unfortunately we only have this many
queries to spend to do the killing and
that's where the rub of the algorithm is
so the remaining challenge is to figure
out how to kill all the end gates with
overly high fan in but we only have
square root of n times Q of F queries to
do it and I only am going to give you
like the highest level sense of how we
do this cuz it's a somewhat short talk
and I'd rather talk about implication to
the result the idea is that we're going
to iterate it early growver search for
these input bits that are 0 but we'll
wind up killing many - and end games so
I'm hiding a lot of details here but
there's some kind of accounting argument
that we do to both bound the the cost of
the grover searches and make sure that
each Grover search kills a lot of end
gates taking a step back the the
high-level outline is actually not
unique to this work we're spending
queries to simplify the circuit by
reducing the fin on the bottom and gates
this is a kind of argument that comes up
in circuit complexity quite a lot for
example a prominent example this kind of
argument is in the so called method of
deterministic restrictions when you see
this in circuit complexity though
typically the goal is not to give a
query algorithm it's to kind of find
some inputs so that you simplify this
circuit all the way down to a constant
while looking about fixing a few bits of
the input so you see this in random
restrictions deterministic restrictions
here we're giving an actual quantum
query algorithm which is kind of a in
some sense a stronger goal and later in
the talk I'll actually talk about some
implications that this query algorithm
has two circuit complexity so it'll kind
of give back to circuit complexity just
as it's been inspired by some arguments
in circuit complexity so our analog for
approximate degree our proof right so
let me go back to where I mentioned it
so the analog for approximate degree we
actually proved with completely
different techniques that are kind of
just mild generalizations of techniques
that have appeared in recent works of
our my work with Marc and Robin and also
a work of Sascha and we discovered the
approximate degree results first and
they're actually completely different
than the quantum query techniques I
think we would have never even thought
to try to prove the quantum result if we
didn't know that the approximate degree
was always true but the techniques are
totally different it emerges really just
because that is the fan-in we can
tolerate the fennan of the end gates we
can tolerate to apply kind of the
trivial upper bound that ignore sharing
of inputs and still get out the result
we want so if every the end function on
n over Q of F bits has quantum query
complexity square root of that just
because of Grover's search and that's
exactly what we're able to multiply Q of
F by and get this bound we could try to
reduce the fennan further but then it
turns out we would actually have to
spend more than this many queries to do
that simplification so we kind of have
two phases of the algorithm one to
simplify the circuit and then another to
just evaluate to simplified circuit and
this bound comes out when you set the
cost of the two phases to be equal
three of the and gates that you trying
to find and quite a complexity of the
first space that the rover search yeah I
mean the paper only works it out with
this particular goal in mind but
so that's our main results about quantum
query algorithms and now I'll spend much
the rest of talk just talking about
implications of this result okay so one
implication is a efficient quantum query
algorithm for any linear size constant
depth circuit okay so specifically for a
linear size depth D circuit you can get
a quantum query algorithm that will only
look at n to the 1 minus 2 to the minus
D bits of the input so for any constant
D this is polynomially less than n so
it's a non-trivial result since trivial
is just look at all and bits of the
input the idea is the following so we
already knew that for depth 1 circuits
which is just like an or function the
quantum query complexity it could be
root N and it was actually shown in
Prior work at Charlotte Kothari and
Kimmel the depth 2 case that you can get
an upper bound of n to the 3/4 for depth
- but it wasn't known what the right
bound was for higher depths and so the
idea here is that a depth real inner
sized circuit is just imagined without
loss of generality that the bottom layer
is is n gates the the gates near the
input so you just have the composition
of a linear size depth to circuit and n
gates and you can apply our composition
theorem to it and you get the geometric
mean of n to the 3/4 for the depth to
circuit and N and that gives you under
the 7/8 and your just iterate so this
actually matches a nearly matches a
lower bound that was shown in this
child's catarrian Kimmel paper which is
off by a constant factor here and I'll
actually during the open questions part
of this talk I'll actually come back to
this argument and explain how it works
because an interesting open question is
going to be to eliminate this constant
factor that's hidden here ok an
immediate algorithmic implication of
this result is that depth D linear sized
circuits can be agnostic lepak learned
in time exponential in n to the 1 minus
2 to the minus D
no this is distribution independently
yes so anytime you have a quantum query
algorithm for a class of functions
actually you only need an approximate
degree upper bound for the class of
functions you get a agnostic tack
learning algorithm for arbitrary
distributions and that's what this gives
you okay so that's an implication to
learn ability of circuits now I want to
mention an implication to circuit lower
bounds this is actually not in our paper
yeah this is non proper learning so no I
wrote agnostic to mean it can handle
adversarial classification noise yeah so
this algorithm will basically find a low
degree polynomial that is it does l1
regression at one point I'm regression
to find a low degree polynomial that is
sort of consistent with the training
data
so this implication for circuit lower
bounds I'm about to describe is not in
the paper but we'll probably add it to
it at some point so there's an important
frontier problem in circuit complexity
which is showing that inner product mod
2 cannot be computed by polynomial size
AC 0 circuits with parity gates at the
bottom so this turns out to be a special
case of a number of really you know
frontier long-standing open problems and
circumplex states received a fair bit of
attention in recent years and the
best-known lower bound is that IP 2
cannot be computed by depth DAC 0
circuits with mod 2 gates at the bottom
of slightly superlinear size so you need
size at least n to the 1 + 4 to the -
depth so you know we think the answer is
probably you need super polynomial size
we can show slightly superlinear size so
there's a big gap between what we think
is true what we can show so an
implication of our results for linear
size is a zero Circuit's is a kind of a
two fold improvement over this prior
work so one improvement is we can
improve this four to the minus D - 2 to
the minus D so it's even slightly more
super linear but maybe that's not so
interesting qualitatively it's a little
more interesting may be that we our
lower bound holds even for it's a
correlation lower bound so it holds even
if the circuit only computes inner
product mod 2 correctly on slightly more
than half of all inputs I guess I have
about five minutes left which is the
right amount of time to say a little got
open questions so one interesting open
question is is our is our upper bound
for depth D linear sized circuits tight
okay so we know where composition
theorem is tight but it's possible that
you can prove an upper bound for depth D
linear sized circuits without going
through that kind of composition theorem
so our upper bound nearly matches a
known lower bound but there's this
constant factor gap in this like
exponent of the exponent it'd be
interesting to close that as I'll
explain on the next slide one way to
accomplish this I think probably the
right way to accomplish this is to
exhibit a quadratic sized DNF
with essentially maximal quantum query
complexity so I'll explain in a second
on the next slide why that would be
enough so we'll come back to that
alternatively if you could show that
every quadratic sized DNF has sub linear
quantum query complexity I think that
would be very surprising and extremely
interesting so regardless of whether
resolving this question will achieve the
goal on the slide the resolution will be
interesting we either achieve their goal
on the slide this way or you have a
really really interesting quantum query
algorithm okay so let me explain why
understanding quadratic sized DNS is
enough to understand linear size AC 0
linear size DNF we have we know an upper
bound of n to the 3/4 that was actually
shown by a child's Kothari and kimmo and
our work kind of recovers that and
generalizes it it's the we don't have a
matching lower bound so there's a lower
bound that's better than root n it's
something like n to the point 5 6 or
something so there's a gap also for
linear sized units but if you resolve
this question then about quadratic sized
DN apps you would also resolve the
question for linear size DN F's and I
will explain why right now ok so
Beamen mark Meucci showed several years
ago that there's a DEP 3 AC 0 circuit of
quadratic sized called called the
surjectivity function definition won't
be important for this which has
essentially maximal quantum query
complexity and then Sasha more recently
actually showed is truly maximal right
they Sasha have removed the log factor
from the lower bound okay so there's
this transformation by child's Kothari
and kimmel what they do is they show how
to turn basically a a quadratic sized
circuit of high quantum query complexity
into a linear sized circuit of nearly
the same quantum query complexity and
that's why this question
about quadratic sized DNS turns out to
be related and basically almost
equivalent to the question about linear
size DNS or circuits in general so let
me tell you that transformation okay so
see here is a quadratic sized circuit
with maximal query complexity and we
want a linear size circuit with high
query complexity so what you can do is
you can look at the quadratic sized
circuit but to find only one root n
inputs so now that's a linear size
circuit in N and then you can you can
compose that block composed with the n
function on root n inputs and now you
actually have a linear size circuit on n
inputs and we have we understand how
quantum query complexity behaves on the
block composition and the bound that
comes out for this composition is
exactly the product of n to the one half
and square root of n to the one half so
that gives you an end of the 3/4 lower
bound for what turns out to be a depth
three circuit so this is depth 3 but the
bottom gates are n gates so when you
compose it with end it's still depth 3
and then you can iterate this argument
so now you just look at the block
composition of surjectivity or and the
one 1/2 inputs with this linear size
thing from the previous stage and then
of the 1/2 inputs and it improves the
lower bound to end of the 7/8 but now
it's step 5 instead of depth 3 and you
just can keep going
so it's like bootstraps a lower bound
for quadratic sized circuits into a
lower bound for linear sized circuits
and the only reason it doesn't match our
upper bound is because the quadratic
sized circuit with maximal query
complexity was depth three not depth of
two okay so if you had that lower bound
for depth to quadratic size you would
match our upper bound so I think that's
an interesting question
okay and now derive like is that clock
slow do I have two minutes okay that's
better than slow yeah okay so maybe I'll
get through two more questions okay so
it would also be interesting to
generalize our composition theorem in
some way so maybe it holds for functions
more general than just the end function
here something I wanted to mention is
that you have to if you're going to try
to generalize this you have to be
careful because it turns out if you try
to reverse the roles of F and ends so if
you look at an end of copies of death
instead of an F of copies of n then this
result turns out to be completely false
and actually the counter example there
is surjectivity but I won't explain why
that's true it's not 100% obvious how to
map surjectivity into this so there are
probably generalizations of this you can
prove of our result but you're gonna
have to be careful how you do it you for
example you can't just reverse the roles
of F and end or you can't show anything
non-trivial okay right so I described
some classical implications of a quantum
query upper bounds here to learn ability
and to circuit lower bounds and I think
it'd be interesting to try to discover
more to identify other implications of
these kinds of quantum query upper
bounds so if you show that a circuit
class every circuit in the class has sub
linear quantum query complexity that's
like a really strong structural property
that circuit class just should be
broadly useful so for example I have no
idea if it's possible to use such a
statement to get faster satisfiability
algorithms but you could imagine maybe
it is just cause it's a strong
structural property so I think that
would be an interesting thing to explore
and then finally I guess my last
question is can we move beyond like
linear size ac0 circuits
so you know we showed slightly better
lower bounds for a c0 mod two circuits
is this a path towards actually showing
super polynomial lower bounds for for
such circuits that would presumably
require showing some kind of polynomial
approximability result for all circuits
in this class and maybe I'll just stop
there and if you care to you can just
read the last two bullet points or so I
believe this is folklore but I can at
least I know that I had a citation
somewhere Avishai in his paper recent
paper on better bipartite formula lower
bounds uses this connection so if if a
circuit class has sub linear approximate
degree you can show that even when you
compose it with parity or anything of
low rank basically that circuits in that
class have to correlate well with parrot
with some parity and we know IP two
doesn't correlate well with any parity
essentially that's the argument
[Applause]